the ps4 Pro is meant to run your games
better and make them look prettier with
4k resolution and HDR display if your TV
can handle it
plenty of developers have stepped up to
improve their games for the new console
so let's take a look at some of the
coolest titles confirmed so far if you
have a 4k television Deus Ex mankind
divided will run at 4k resolution with
many graphical improvements the Elder
Scrolls online will also run at 4k and
will see increased graphical fidelity
even if you don't have a 4k TV fallout 4
will also make use of the pros 4k
capabilities while Middle Earth shadow
of Mordor will be upgraded with super
sampled anti-aliasing NBA 2k 17 will run
natively at 4k and 60 frames per second
with HDR support 2k even says it'll
render that high on non 4k TVs with much
better anti-aliasing epic games MOBA
Paragon is getting a handful of
improvements including better visuals
and textures higher scene complexity and
dynamic reflections rhythm game thumper
will run at 4k with no upscaling and the
PlayStation VR version will keep running
at the same 90 FPS it does now the
witness will also run at a higher
resolution and stick to a constant 30
FPS those are just the games with
confirmed details but plenty more
developers have pledged to upgrade their
current titles let's take a look at a
few of those games
[Music]
the ps4 pro hit store shelves on
November 10th for 400 bucks do you plan
on upgrading your console we'll have
plenty of coverage leading up to launch
day so stay tuned to game spot for all
the latest
[Music]